i've been reviewing windows laptops for
over 4 years now and personally buying
them for over a decade
and even though i'm a big mac fan for
many years
i've still recommended them for many
people up until the end of 2020
but here at the start of 2021 i have to
say that there are three specific
reasons why you need to be
very cautious if you're in the market
for a new laptop and why buying one
right now could be a huge mistake and no
i'm not just gonna go out and tell you
to buy an m1 mac
instead of course there are still
reasons to buy one
and specific laptops that do make sense
so i'll make sure to cover that at the
end
and give you some tips on how to get a
great laptop that'll have great
performance
a good all-around experience and won't
cost you a ton of money
like it did me as many of you know we've
mostly been focusing on compact 13 and
14-inch
lightweight windows laptops that have
become the mainstream
since they finally became decent in the
last few years
before that most ultrabooks that were
trying to copy the macbook air were
failing
miserably their keyboards were way worse
than 15-inch laptops the displays were
very dim and reflective
track pads were horrible and the same
thing goes with speakers i bought an
acer ultrabook
four to five years ago and it was pure
garbage
and i ended up returning it for a mac
that cost more but the experience was so
much better even though the specs were
worse but when we started to review them
every upgrade cycle had decent
improvements starting with the build
quality getting solid
with companies starting to use less
plastic and more premium materials
as time went on we got improved webcams
battery life finally started to compete
with max
companies started putting in better ssds
speakers were actually becoming usable
keyboards were also superior to apple's
butterfly keys
and even the diving board trackpads
finally became responsive enough to use
without needing a separate mouse not
only that but intel
finally started stepping up and creating
better processors as well
when their 10 nanometer finally came out
which resulted in battery life that
could beat out a macbook with older
processors
and performance that was also a little
bit better and
some laptops were actually offering
better cooling as well they also had
some unique features that we loved like
windows hello for login
slimmer bezels and overall size as well
of course prices
also went up at the same time to close
to that or even exceeding apple's
macbooks
but that made sense due to how much
better the components were
because of that we routinely started to
recommend them and we're saying that if
you don't need mac os
these windows laptops were definitely a
better buy and that was the case
just six or so months ago especially
with the dell xps 13 9310
it was an absolute killer laptop with
the display that was just as bright and
color accurate as the macbook pros
and not only that it was actually less
reflective as well
which was a first for any windows laptop
and the keyboard
is actually better than apple's brand
new magic keyboard
in their new max but now i would be very
careful buying one
or any of the great alternatives that we
reviewed why
well here is why i am frustrated and
here's what's changed in just half a
year
first off you guys know that the biggest
change in the laptop
space is apple's m1 processors but that
goes
way deeper than apple having better
processor performance than last year
which i'll explain and i also have
multiple other reasons to share but
we'll start out with that back in june
after apple announced the upcoming apple
silicon max the team was super excited
and he started making a series of videos
about them
now a lot of people including me thought
that he was being
way too hyped up about the new apple
silicon chips
and you couldn't really blame us all of
the windows laptops that used arm
processors
that made huge promises in battery life
and performance
ended up being terrible benchmarks were
so so
but once you've factored in the price
and the real world performance
and especially compatibility these arm
machines showed us that arm
wasn't ready for the mainstream but
vadim wouldn't give up
he dug into apple's white papers and
super long press conference videos
designed for engineers and developers
and found very
interesting bits of information that
made it into videos
and got the attention of tech
enthusiasts along with even
creators which called him out on his
grandiose predictions but you know what
he was absolutely right when apple
launched the m1 max even though the
machines looked exactly the same
we were blown away at the performance
numbers but we were still a little bit
skeptical because they seemed
too good to be true at the same time
apple ended up effectively lowering the
average price of the m1 macbook air to
999 dollars
and while at launch i thought it was the
least interesting m1 mac
this machine is what is hurting windows
laptops
most in 2021 and after doing extensive
testing
we found out that apple didn't over hype
their m1 chips with the performance and
battery life that they advertised
but they were actually being too
conservative in many cases
these m1 machines absolutely killed the
intel-based macbooks that came out
earlier this year
and did so while staying cooler and
quieter
and in many cases they cost less as well
not only that but in certain use cases
my m1 mac mini smokes my 15 000
mac pro and in many others it keeps up
while costing less
than 1 15 of the price which is insane
these arm chips are crazy and because of
this
intel just pushed a huge media campaign
trying to throw shade on apple
and promoting different windows laptops
just to keep trying to sell their
processors to these major brands
and don't worry i'll explain why this
matters for windows laptops as well
after a few months and tons and tons of
testing in our long term review
we finally gave our verdict that the m1
macbook air is the best mac to buy
as it performs almost as well as the pro
while being completely silent
and costing 300 less at the same time
and on top of that
for just a few bucks you can get it to
outperform the pro
for just 999 dollars and more than that
it is the perfect laptop or as close as
you can get
and with us everybody noticed as well
resulting in max sales growing
50 compared to the previous year which
is insane
and it makes sense why for the first
time we had windows fans praising apple
instead of hating on them
some buying m1 max when they have been
avoiding macbooks
for years or even decades at the same
time i had posted a few windows laptops
for sale
great ones like microsoft surface book 3
and the dell xps
it's been over 6 months since i posted
that machine
and no one wants to buy it i priced it
low
even though this thing was 2700 brand
new with 32 gigs of ram
higher than a 4k display literally
specked
out and now it's priced down to a
thousand dollars
and i can't get anyone to buy it and i
can't really blame them
dell has also been dropping their prices
a 2700
laptop is now 1935 probably because they
aren't selling
and even though it might be tempting to
pick up one of these machines
i wouldn't recommend it i said at the
start that i'm not just going to suggest
buying an m1 mac
and i won't but that definitely is a
better option
not only is an m1 macbook air way more
powerful it's also cheaper and at the
same time the resale value will be
way better every mac that i've posted
has sold
in just a few days even the intel ones
not m1
my 1800 4 port sold for 1400
in one day whereas the 2700 xps has been
up for over six months
and can't sell for even a thousand and i
know some of you might say that you can
only get 16 gigs of ram
on an m1 macbook but that 16 gigs
performs way better than 16 gigs in a
windows machine
as we showed off on our xps comparison
in that ram section
which i'll link down below and when
comparing two similarly priced mac
and windows machines like the new lg
gram which is a great all-around laptop
the m1 air is better in basically every
single way
and costs 200 less and on top of that
you can sell it a year later for almost
no loss
whereas nobody's gonna want to buy your
lg which is why dave lee had to make an
update video saying that the macbook air
is too
good and that's the next reason why you
probably shouldn't be buying a windows
laptop
in 2021 unless it's maybe the end of
2021.
everybody now knows that thanks to
apple's push arm is finally going to hit
the mainstream
these machines have been out for years
now with arm processors and windows
laptops but nobody
cared because the software just wasn't
there but as soon as m1 came out
software companies scrambled to make
their x86 apps work for
arm and this is massively helping
microsoft as well
if you're going to buy a windows
ultrabook it is going to be outdated
faster than ever before and it will be
replaced by similar windows machines
using upcoming arm processors
that will bring better performance in
silent and cool packages
with killer battery life and you will
soon want to upgrade
just like many mac users did but unlike
a mac
it will be very tough to sell it so
you'll either have to give it away for
almost no money back or just gift it to
somebody that you know
because of that if you want to buy a
laptop in 2021
unless it's a gaming laptop i would
either try your best to wait just a bit
longer
for a great new windows r machine or buy
a mac in the meantime
arm is finally here and it's changing
the laptop world and if you absolutely
need a windows laptop and you need it
now
buy it from somebody like me who has a
crazy machine that they can't sell
and will give it away for relatively
nothing go ahead and check out vadim's
vid on how apple finally put the final
nail in intel's coffin right over there
and if you enjoyed this video click
above to subscribe to help us reach
1 million subscribers in 2021
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]